on va on va parler de la de la crise
démocratique et des outils pour lutter
contre cette crise démocratique d'abord
un mot peut-être avec vous Paul Cassia
elle est profonde cette crise
démocratique aujourd'hui en tout cas il
y a une crise démocratique qui est je
crois actée par toutes et tous elle a
été reconnue par le Président de la
République lors de son élection en 2022
et il s'était engagé à y remédier au
cours de son mandat et on attend de
savoir comment est-ce que il sera
possible de se départir de ce crise
démocratique pour l'instant les outils
existent peut-être dans la Constitution
on va le voir ensemble ce matin mais ils
n'ont pas encore été tous utilisés et on
va on va le voir tout de suite puisque
parmi ces outils Alex il y a la question
du référendum Emmanuel Macron il
réfléchit à élargir le recours au
référendum effectivement le président de
la République a écrit la semaine
dernière aux différents chefs de partis
politiques pour revenir sur leur
rencontre fin août à Saint-Denis et
voilà ce qui leur écrit plusieurs
participants à ces rencontres ont
manifesté leur volonté de recourir plus
simplement au référendum et détendre le
chant de l'article le 11 de la
Constitution je vous propose de vous
faire une proposition sur ce sujet dans
les semaines qui viennent écrire le
président de la République alors déjà on
va regarder ce que dit l'article 11 de
la Constitution qui porte sur
l'utilisation du référendum il précise
que les Français ne peuvent être
consultés que sur trois thèmes
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics la
ratification des traités internationaux
on souvient du référendum de 2005 sur le
traité européen et le nom des Français
et puis troisième thème sur la politique
économique et sociale ça veut dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron aurait pu faire un
référendum sur la réforme des retraites
c'est d'ailleurs ce que lui demande
encore aujourd'hui les chefs de parties
de gauche mais il est hors de question
pour Emmanuel Macron de rouvrir cette
page de la réforme des retraites en
revanche le président de la République
est plus attentif à ce que demande la
droite et l'extrême droite les
républicains et le rassemblement
national à savoir un référendum sur le
thème de l'immigration un thème qui ne
rentre pas actuellement dans le champ du
référendum dans le champ de l'article 11
il faudrait donc modifier cet article 11
de la Constitution et Alex il faut
d'abord donc procéder la révision de la
Constitution la manière est compliquée
oui pour réviser notre texte fondamental
il y a plusieurs étapes à passer d'abord
le projet de loi constitutionnelle doit
être adopté par les deux Chambres du
Parlement dans les termes identiques on
le rappelle le Sénat à une majorité les
républicains l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale une majorité
présidentielle mais relative c'est donc
compliqué un d'obtenir un accord parfait
sur un tel texte et si cette étape est
passée le projet de révision de la
Constitution doit être approuvé par
référendum ou alors à la majorité des
3/5 du Parlement qui serait réunies en
congrès le chemin ça donc s'annonce donc
long pour élargir le champ du référendum
au thème de l'immigration et puis au
sein de la majorité présidentielle on
n'est pas forcément très chaud pour le
faire regardez ce qui a répondu le
patron du parti Renaissance Stéphane
séjourné à la lettre du président de la
République je le cite la question de
l'élargissement du champ du référendum
en particulier pour organiser un scrutin
autour de l'immigration nous app araît
délicate et mérite une attention
particulière pour éviter toute division
supplémentaire de la société et puis
écouter ce que dit le ministre de la
Fonction publique Stanislas Guérini
Oriane vous lui posiez à la question
lundi sur ce plateau
un gendarme sur les migrations pour vous
c'est oui
personnellement je crois que c'est pas
le sujet qui est le plus pertinent à
présenter en référendum il faut pouvoir
je le disais à l'instant avancer
efficacement sans idéologie mal placée
si je peux dire sur ces sujets là avec
pragmatisme je crois pas que ce soit le
sujet principal au sujet de quoi
pertinent trop clivant
et qui crée effectivement un clivage
important et donc voilà l'idée d'un
référendum sur l'immigration pour
l'instant ne recueille pas une majorité
de voix dans la classe politique merci
Alex Paul Cassia ça peut être la
solution le référendum c'est déjà la
solution puisque le référendum est pris
par la Constitution Alex la indiqué le
champ du référendum il a déjà été élargi
depuis 1958 il a été élargi deux fois il
a été élargi en 1995 on a ajouté les
éléments de politique et économique et
sociales il a été élargi en 2008 on a
ajouté le référendum d'initiative
partagée on en a parlé au moment des
retraites et malgré deux élargissements
il n'y a eu que 9 référendum depuis 1958
donc on a déjà des outils on parle de
l'immigration qui n'est pas dans le
champ du référendum mais on aurait déjà
pu faire des référendums sur bien
d'autres sujets depuis 2017 il n'y en a
pas eu donc je trouve que aujourd'hui
mais comment comment vous l'expliquez
parce que vous dites c'est déjà la
solution c'est un outil certes qui est à
la disposition des présidents de la
République sauf qu'ils s'en servent pas
pourquoi alors pourquoi je ne sais pas
il faudrait leur demander il y a
peut-être une crainte de
personnalisation du scrutin un risque
plébiscitaire l'idée c'est que la
question posée ne serait pas tellement
l'objet du référendum mais la personne
qui la pose voilà mais sinon je ne sais
pas pourquoi je ne peux pas je ne peux
pas vous dire pourquoi cet outil n'est
pas utilisé je le regrette à titre
personnel il faut rappeler que le
dernier référendum date de 2005 ça va
faire maintenant 20 ans qu'il n'y a pas
eu de référendum or l'article 3 de notre
Constitution dit que notre souveraineté
s'exerce à la fois par nos représentants
et nos représentants et par la voie du
un homme donc c'est un outil qui existe
qui peut être utilisé à tout moment par
le Président de la République voir par
le parlementaire via une proposition de
loi constitutionnelle et qui n'est
jamais mise en or malgré les débats
récurrents qu'on a sur ce sujet donc il
y a une part un petit peu de
d'enfumage sur ce sujet de la mais c'est
vrai il faut il faut dire les choses
comme elles sont de la part de nos
représentants et ne représentants qui
parlent du référendum sans s'en servir
alors qu'ils ont les moyens pour cela
c'est de l'enfumage on sait aussi
peut-être parce qu'un risque politique à
utiliser le référendum Arnaud ont-ils
peur du peuple la question fondamentale
qu'il faut se poser en l'occurrence si
vous voulez moi je suis d'accord avec ce
qui vient d'être dit c'est à dire que
les outils pour faire vivre la
démocratie ils existent dans la
constitution de la 5ème république
général de Gaulle et les fondateurs de
la Cinquième République avaient une
fidélité assez bien pensé le régime et
il considérait d'ailleurs que quand il y
avait un problème de légitimité c'était
au peuple de trancher il y a une
déclaration de Michel Debrie qui est
très intéressante
dans les années au début en 60 ou 61 qui
l'explique qu'il explique très bien tout
se passe comme si finalement nos
dirigeants avaient perdu un peu le fil
de l'esprit même de la Constitution et
la réalité c'est que je pense que
pourquoi aujourd'hui le référendum n'est
pas activé sur un certain nombre de
questions c'est parce que il y a un
trauma qui s'est installé dans la classe
politique française et notamment parmi
ces dirigeants et parmi ces responsables
c'est le référendum de 2005 le
référendum de 2005 ou les Français ont
majoritairement voté non au projet le
traité constitutionnel européen projet
qui a été quand même il faut le rappeler
ensuite réintroduit en grande partie via
le traité de Lisbonne je pense que en
effet cet événement est un événement
très important de la vie politique
française qui explique aussi peut-être
en partie les raisons de la
démobilisation électorale un certain
nombre de Français considérons que
finalement le vote est aujourd'hui
démonétisée et que aller voter de toute
façon ne sert à rien puisque une fine et
une fine et les responsables politiques
n'écoutent pas la voix des urnes donc
si vous voulez on voit bien que
supérieur sur le sujet de l'immigration
qui en effet ne fait pas partie du champ
du référendum quoique il y a des il y a
des aspects économiques et sociaux qui
sont liés aux politiques migratoires on
voit bien que sur cette question quand
on entend les responsables minist les
hommes sur l'immigration sans changer la
constitution aujourd'hui difficile en
l'occurrence en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il va peut-être essayer alors
il y a en plus il y a le contexte du
projet de loi sur l'immigration où on
sait que les républicains ont fait un
certain nombre de propositions on voit
que le Président de la République
apparemment semble faire un pas en leur
direction sur ce sujet vraisembe avant
parce qu'il se dit que l'adoption de son
texte sur l'immigration à l'Assemblée
nationale sera certainement beaucoup
plus compliqué qu'il ne le pensait il y
a quelques mois mais on voit bien quand
même les réactions des principaux
responsables de la majorité quand on
leur pose la question de savoir si il
faut utiliser le référendum sur la
question migratoire au-delà du problème
constitutionnel que ça se porte et que
ça pose
mais quand on regarde les études
d'opinion et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant c'est que les Français
majoritairement eux veulent être d'une
certaine façon consulter sur la question
migratoire il y a un déphasage si vous
voulez aujourd'hui ça ça me paraît je
pense le j'allais dire le nœud de la
crise démocratique entre l'aspiration
des Français à être plus écoutées plus
entendu de plus participer à la prise de
décision et finalement
l'inertie des responsables politiques à
répondre à cette répondre à cette
demande et tant qu'on aura pas résolu ce
problème je crains que la crise
démocratique continue perdure voir ce
consolide et se renfonce on va y revenir
mais Paul cassis sur ce que disait
Arnaud sur le référendum sur
l'immigration qu'est-ce qu'il est
possible de faire aujourd'hui
tout sauf un référendum sur
l'immigration donc on parle de quelque
chose qui est en l'état ne peut pas
avoir lieu et qui ne pourra avoir lieu
ça a été rappelé par Alex tout à l'heure
que s'il y a au préalable une révision
constitutionnelle il n'y aura pas de
révision constitutionnelle ça fait
maintenant six ans que on parle d'une
révision constitutionnelle sous les
mandats d'Emmanuel Macron il a présenté
des projets en ce sens lors du
quinquennat précédent qui n'ont pas été
adoptés il n'y a aucune chance en l'état
de la législature y compris à venir à la
suite des résultats des élections
sénatoriales qu'il y a une une vision
constitutionnelle est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas le poids politique
suffisant pour l'affaire pour
différentes raisons et notamment
celle-ci et notamment le fait que les
oppositions n'ont pas de raison de faire
un cadeau au président de la République
qui ne peut pas se représenter juste un
petit point qui ne faut pas oublier
c'est que il était prévu de réviser la
Constitution sur l'IVG et sur ce point
même qui pourtant fait consensus les
chambres ne sont pas intervenues à se
mettre d'accord sur un texte commun et
le président est
non représentants s'accordent pour ne
pas soumettre ce texte à référendum donc
il y a des sujets qu'on veut présenter
un référendum comme l'immigration alors
qu'ils ne peuvent pas l'être et il y a
d'autres sujets comme l'IVG qu'on
pourrait présenter un référendum mais
que nos représentants ne veulent pas
nous soumettre pour des raisons tenantes
à au débat qui pourrait disons avoir une
qualité dégradée
tout à l'heure il est plusieurs côtés
dans la classe politique c'est mon
sentiment personnel de citoyen voilà
donc tout est fait pour que le
référendum ne soit pas utilisé avec des
raisons qui peuvent se justifier qui
peuvent se comprendre mais de fait le
référendum n'est pas utilisé et Arnaud a
parfaitement rappelé que il y avait une
aspiration à participer à la prise de
décision avec le risque ça implique que
cette prise de décision ne correspond
pas aux aspirations de nos dirigeants
nationaux et que après on se retrouve
dans la même situation quand en 2005 ou
finalement le résultat du référendum est
surpassé avec les effets délétères que
ça pour pour notre système démocratique
moi je crois que ce débat est assez
virtuel en l'état des rapports de force
en effet parlementaire c'est que la
révision constitutionnelle c'est un
serpent de mer j'allais dire de la
présidence Macron on a vu qu'elle a pas
été possible lors du premier mandat et
elle me semble encore moins possible
lors de ce second mandat compte tenu
notamment de la composition de
l'Assemblée nationale or il y a des tas
de sujets il y a des tas de sujets il y
a la Nouvelle-Calédonie il y a la Corse
il y a en effet l'amélioration des
outils en vue j'allais dire de rendre
plus vivante la vie démocratique mais il
finit aujourd'hui personne même j'allais
dire dans l'état du champ politique a
intérêt à aller vers cette révision pour
des raisons qui sont d'abord des raisons
j'allais dire strictement politique et
de rapport de force je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui les oppositions contenu
jaillir de l'état de l'opinion contenu
des rapports de force au Parlement faire
un cadeau à la majorité présidentielle
en lui facilitant l'adoption d'une
réforme constitutionnelle qui serait
inévitablement portée au crédit quand
même de la majorité présidentielle donc
dans l'état ce débat qui est très
intéressant sur le plan j'allais dire
intellectuel sur le plan constitutionnel
sur le plan politique me paraît avoir
peu de chances d'aboutir au cours de
cette législature mais après tout en
politique il peut y avoir des miracles
ça arrive parfois ça s'appelle
l'histoire est-ce que c'est lié aussi
Paul casser à la limitation du nombre de
mandats présidentiel à deux est-ce que
du coup ça bloque le quinquennat
je ne sais pas je ne pense pas que ça
bloque le quinquennat puisque le
président de la République encore quatre
ans pour agir c'est quand même pas rien
d'avoir 10 ans de mandats je trouve que
c'est une durée qui est largement
suffisante je rappelle quand même que en
2008 la limitation à deux quinquennats a
été adopté sous la présidence de Nicolas
Sarkozy précisément pour revivifier la
démocratie
et moi je ne vois pas d'un mauvais œil
le fait qu'une personne ne puisse pas se
représenter immédiatement après avoir
exercé deux mandats successifs ce qui
n'empêchera pas cette personne pour
reprendre les mots d'Emmanuel Macron moi
je trouve que c'est une très bonne
réforme
voilà qui me semble de bonne augure et
je suis content qu'il y a un
renouvellement du personnel politique et
puis ce n'est pas depuis quelques mois
qui Emmanuel découvre le problème du
manque de vitalité démocratique de notre
pays rappelez-vous en 2018 fin 2018 au
moment de la crise des gilets jaunes et
pancarte qu'on voyait le plus dans les
rues c'était les pancartes Rick
référendum d'initiatives citoyenne quand
Emmanuel Macron fait sa grande
conférence de presse pour proposer les
solutions à cette crise des gilets
jaunes justement il dit qu'il va baisser
le seuil pour faire des référendum
d'initiative citoyennes il propose
également à la Convention citoyenne pour
le climat où il dit qu'il reprendra sans
filtre les propositions des citoyens sur
l'écologie au final ce n'est pas le cas
le gouvernement fait un texte climatique
à sa sauce il y a donc une déception à
propos à propos de cette convention
citoyenne et puis l'autre déception
démocratique elle était autour de la
réforme des retraites avec une opinion
publique qui était majoritairement
contre cette réforme des retraites les
élus notamment macronistes disaient les
sons vivre le débat parlementaire et au
final ce texte n'a même pas été voté par
l'Assemblée nationale donc il y a
plusieurs déceptions démocratiques qui
qui sont qui ont eu lieu dans les
mandats d'Emmanuel Macron oui c'est
toute la question des mots et des actes
c'est-à-dire que c'est vrai que on a un
président de la République qui actent
l'existence d'une crise démocratique qui
envisage de mettre en place un certain
nombre d'outils pour résoudre cette
crise démocratique mais qui infinie ne
passe pas à l'action parce que tout
simplement il y a vraisemblablement
aussi malgré tout pour la question du
référendum une méfiance très forte qui
existe
parmi à certains nombre de dirigeants
parmi les élites vis-à-vis de ce que
pourrait donner le résultat d'un
référendum encore une fois je pense que
le référendum de 2005 sur l'Europe sur
ce sujet qui est particulièrement
clivant à profondément traumatisé une
partie de la classe dirigeante de ce
pays
on en parle depuis les gilets jaunes
depuis 2019 et rien n'a été fait rien
n'a été fait depuis juste un petit mot
pour rappeler qu'au moment de la réforme
des retraites dont Alex qu'Alex évoquet
il y a un instant on nous a dit qu'on ne
pouvait pas nous consulter par
référendum parce que le sujet je cite
était trop compliqué pour les Français
trop compliqué alors même que nous avons
voté le traité de Maastricht en 1992 qui
était bien plus compliqué que la réforme
des retraites et que le traité de Nice
de 2005 nous a été soumis qui était
beaucoup plus compliqué que la réforme
de retraite donc il a toujours une bonne
ou une mauvaise raison pour ne pas
consulter les Françaises et les Français
par référendum merci Monsieur pour ce
débat
[Musique]